always wash the dirt
now that our fruits washed I'm going to
attempt to cut my very first pineapple
ever okay cutting a pineapple the first
step is cut off the top and it says to
get a real sharp knife and this is a
pretty sharp knife
holy moly my head how are you with this
I can't believe my adult life or my
entire life I've never cut a pineapple
there we go
looks like I'm doing what I'm supposed
to do I should probably do this more
often
because find out a little my favorite
fruits ice we're almost there
deposit listen to the fresh and I guess
we just kind of do this right so let's
cut up our pineapple chunks however
however you want
I have no recommendation those are big
with us already
God what a great pineapples
go on Jana is also allergic to
pineapples this whole weekly video thing
has changed my life I'm making things
that are actually edible and easy so a
bunch of people on YouTube we're telling
me to use a straw to hollow out and
strawberries and I was like you're crazy
that's never gonna work this was just a
straw and not a knife it worked you guys
are smarter than me that's great cool
really interesting technique here you
just dig it in let's just use my big
knife
dibbles the never cut a peach before if
you're wondering how I've made it
through my life this far I'm actually
wondering the same thing a peach has a
pit yeah maybe I just I just try to like
cut around it maybe and get off there
buddy don't you think this is a free
ride note to self get a get a peeler
that doesn't look so good these are nice
peaches though oh you know what I just
got word that somebody in my party
doesn't like peaches so so I quit they
just called they just called and said
they don't like them so I'll put you in
the fridge for someone that likes
peaches you know we can make our little
topping and for this we need 1/4 cups of
milk
that's half color this is one cup one
package of instant banana banana cream
pudding oh I forgot about you okay
next it mix it mix it
how we tried us to make sure it tastes
nice that is a good taste all our fruit
there's our grapes so I start by putting
a little bit of this on the bottom just
please base oh this is getting really
quite chilled quite quickly just get
that nice and nice and just smooth out I
think what I'd like to do is line some
berries I'm gonna line them around this
just a real nice real nice hmm I'm not
sure cool that looks great pineapple
chunks I think you know if I could
recommend one thing I would say maybe
make the pineapple chunks just a little
bit smaller I was gonna put this a limit
top but I feel like I might want to put
a little bit in Oh God just really mix
it all together maybe that was a bad
idea okay let's put a few more
blueberries just to really uh get wild
even though they said they didn't like
peaches I guess where I got the phone
call we're just gonna put a few peaches
there's any other fruits that you guys
really like go for it
toss them in more raspberries or reds
threes this is something that I would
definitely take to a party and be like
hey hello it's me
I've been wondering after all these
years how to cut a pineapple and look at
this
Tomi did it okay we're just gonna smush
those all around just to make it nice
and even
oops big slice now just cut it like this
nice now we're gonna guess we're just
gonna put this pudding all on the top of
it but the problem is it really got
quite not quite chilled maybe I should
have made two servings you guys make
this learn from my mistakes so life is
all about learning from mistakes maybe
we put them like that
how's that look cool whoa
is he excited add some bananas to the
top Wow
BAM hold up I just watch a game one
isn't it
I have a limb Phyllis to take it to the
party
they just my friend they did said they
didn't like peaches so I didn't have to
cut the peaches they called and said no
pictures yeah I was a phone call it was
the photos the phone alone speaker where
we just want dig in since basically I
think the party is the party of two and
this is really only people gonna eat
this so you take that side I think okay
I side well there's a lot of stuff in it
I can't have happy alone you are me we
have only child of my mom I haven't put
it in a while this is like putting what
the sour cream and like mm-hmm
who you guys in here down she says off
on the side
banana pudding if we have an established
it's already Jenna has a banana allergy
this bowl is fantastic because it comes
to the lid
so if you want to take it to the party
you just go like this but I guess I'll
just be taking this to my bedroom
because it's a party of one thank you
guys so much for watching this video
hope you guys enjoyed this amazing fruit
salad because so far I think this might
be one of my favorite things that I've
ever made it's actually pretty simple
and I'm so happy that you guys were able
to witness my first time ever cutting a
pineapple you can save yourself some
time but I just don't even worry about
leaving any comments about how I've made
it my entire life without cutting a
pineapple but I have I'll see you guys
in tomorrow's video thank you for
watching and be sure as always to leave
some comments about what you think you
know tomorrow